doveva doveva finire molto prima questa
rotazione tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video finalmente possiamo
annunciare questo video perché come
sapete tutti ho doppiato il nuovo film
della disney che si chiama on world due
punti oltre alla magia
mamma mia che dovevano un bellissimo
bellissimo siamo andati a roma siamo
andati a salerno abbiamo fatto un sacco
di gilet li vedrete tutti in questo blog
prima di cominciare
voglio dirvi che finalmente all world ha
una data di uscita ed il 19 di agosto
ragazzi mi raccomando andate tutti
quanti al cinema ci vediamo là e chi mi
riconosce riconoscere la mia voce e
vince il canale tanto non ho mai
scommesso il mio canale per niente male
di glielo dici
qual è la voce dove quando e perché se
stupido forma cosa del genere
vabbè non la mettiamo comunque andata al
cinema e guardate l essere ascoltati
soprattutto che abbiamo accesso a bere
godetevi il video ragazzini
ma ti rendi conto di quanto siamo
esageratamente uguali uguali
io me ne rendo conto è intelligente non
lo stato eroga gente non lo sanno ma
nessuno sappia ragazzi perché stiamo
andando incredibilmente a roma
andiamo a roma
prima di empire awards che pronuncia
davanzati bravissimo ma anzi mediazione
mondo esterno lo stava portano sangue
ritiro per inglese a lei però guarda
dovete parlare in italiano perché perché
perché allora lo dobbiamo dell'italiano
eccezione abbiamo anche io lo guardo per
sabrina ferilli
certo che lo rosa prima perilli raul
cremona ed eccolo fumante privati
all'anteprima del film
ragazzi siamo in piazza del popolo dico
io
apprestiamoci ad andare al cinema
ovviamente siamo arrivati ma non ho
guidato io ho guidato lui solo perché io
non ho la patente però lui mi ha
esaminato e mi ha detto che me la può
dare quindi a posto no pro incredibile
cioè e cole di shining ragione ora che
ci sono tra testi in fondo se residenti
quando fichi le gemme
sì mi piace luca ragazzi siamo appena
usciti dal cinema abbiamo visto il film
in anteprima mondiale allora non è
perché ci sono io dentro non me ne frega
niente sincero anche lars bak che era
bello ma questo mamma mia mamma ma non
ho pianto un sacco perché no
lo stava mettendo a posto la mia camera
tra ma veramente c'è quello che sto
vedendo ma dai hai messo il pupazzo di
me nel film è veramente bello
congelamento vicino a poi la spacca
interpreta l'anno scorso ogni anno
facciamo una roba guarda quanto sono io
il mediano il profilo
adesso che il profilo no come stabilì
proprio un pochino ci sono le orecchie
l'ora è bellissimo grazie di tutto
questo siccome la stanza a un valore
semplicemente per il video io succedere
mi pare la mia cosa che quello che
faccio quello che fa vabbè buonanotte
[Musica]
ma è comunque veramente ragazzi mi
dispiace interrompervi ma volevo fare un
ode a roma che è una città bellissima e
piena di sorprese al punto pare che le
sto andando dolore guarda un po grazie
di essere qui con noi per la conferenza
stampa di hong war
oltre alla magia e per aver prestato la
sua voce a questa nuova e tra il disney
e pixar disney sarà a tua completa
disposizione per qualsiasi esigenza
siamo sicuri che sarà una giornata
indimenticabile utili voi lavorate in
disney è il mio turno e non posso fare
questa cosa che sto facendo il mio turno
i lunghissimi impressioni ma non voglio
mai più fare questa cosa la mia vita
orribile se guardo a sinistra perché non
voglio dare uguale non so se tante
evito sul nostro marco ne fa italiani
uguali azzecca mente sempre uguale anche
caratterialmente sono moltissimi secondo
te io sono coraggioso anzi ci pensi
mattina poi sorprende i semi aventino
invece si spera 1 m coupè miseri come di
persone facciamo chiaro si sbroda non
fatemi attivista dietro non sia di
quello che dici perché di tanta lui
coevi di noi non facciamo lo facciamo
teatrali citati veramente un grazie a
una classe che dico perché fera bio
almeno 3 milioni di fan siamo per fare
la foto con il bastone quello vero fai
un passo in là
esatto faccia pazza bastone il po più
verso di te troppo bene li hai rubato
qualcosa io ho preso il monopattino
elettrico in giro a roma ma adesso come
mai visto non ritrovando perché visto
che ho rubato un monopattino elettrico
devo non tolgono camicie ma si erano
scrive perché no poi mi riconoscono non
è che devi fare un iter ragazzi stiamo
tornando a casa
siamo in piazza del popolo dopo a piedi
bellissimo
ecco
no non lo so giorno giorno 16 lui 16
luglio eravamo partiti a febbraio tarda
a roma
senti pero io non lo so ma non ho
controllato ma dove siamo finiti così
c'è scritto salerno siamo finiti a
salerno a piedi ho detto dammi la mappa
per milano dove mandare mandato si può
mandare un opera non so siamo andati
sotto
comunque a salerno il suo periodo che io
sappia c'è zipponi infatti c'è un canale
a giffoni ha dentro numero uno vicino al
mondo per i ragazzi andiamo al collo
3 oppure no quindi ragazzi non posso
urlare perché sono nell'otello alla fine
siamo tornati stavolta non a piedi ma
con la macchina e abbiamo finito
l'esperienza del ciccione è stato
fantastico evento e ragazzi rimane solo
da vedere il film al cinema quindi ci
vediamo prossimamente lì io andrò a
rivederlo perché l'ho visto ma lo
rivedrò di nuovo perché mi emoziono a
vedere vedermi insomma vedere che il mio
personaggio si spiaccicano già detto nel
video si spiaccica sulla si spiaccica
sul vetro dell'auto e vendere questo
film di nuovo e bellissimo da parte ci
vediamo al cinema ragazzi
[Musica]